So how do neurons send signals to and from the brain? Well let's take the
example that you have a bee flying around your head. You either see it or you
hear it. Your sensory neurons pick up this information and send it to your
brain to be processed. Then your motor neurons take this signal and send it to
your muscles and that allows you to swat the bee away or get up and run,
whatever you're going to do. Now how these messages are sent are because of an
action potential. Now an action potential is an explosion of electricity that
sends information down an axon away from the cell body. When the electrical
voltage of a neuron reaches a threshold level, that's when the action potential
fires. Now this electrical impulse triggers a chemical release and that's how
neurons communicate with each other. There's a lot more details that go into
these. So I'm going to let Greg explain it to you a little better.